[Music]
that is rome and it's rome for a reason
a home fit for a princess is on the
market in italy you'll need the budget
of a billionaire however to get it so
take a look at the property it's known
as villa aurora and it is a 16th century
estate among the most expensive homes
for sale anywhere in the world valued at
more than half a billion dollars it did
however fail at auction yesterday not
sure why the home comes with rare
masterpieces from the art world and so
many rooms that the current owner does
not even bother to count them what are
you gonna do chris livesay got a tour of
the home and he's got more now on the
american-born princess and the place she
lived and why she's leaving it chris
good morning
good morning tony yeah it's got the
makings of a fairy tale a real-life
prince meets a woman from texas makes
her a princess and gives her this
historic villa that's virtually
exploding with art all of it priceless
well almost priceless
any rome villa is bound to cost a
princely sun we're in the aurora room
but the 16th century villa aurora comes
with its own princess there are 10
secret messages in each of these alcoves
we see that's real gold that they used
to paint with and none are more colorful
than her serene highness the principessa
rita bon compagnie lurovisi one of the
people from the louvre was here and she
said we have one of these at the louvre
but this is in much better shape
you might know her better as rita
generette in 1980 this texas girl was
married to south carolina congressman
john generette when he was convicted of
fraud the next year as her marriage was
crumbling she threw gasoline on the
fiery scandal and posed for playboy she
eventually found her footing in
manhattan real estate helping donald
trump broker his purchase of the general
motors building in 1998. that's the
period when she met her second husband a
direct descendant of pope gregory xiii
prince nicolo boncompagni ludovisi seen
here on cbs sunday morning in 2017. tell
me about the moment you laid eyes on
rita oh
that's a moment i will never forget he
died in 2018 sparking a bitter
inheritance dispute between his children
from a previous marriage and princess
rita one she says makes the hbo series
succession look tame they could take the
company out of our hands and we'd never
get near it again are you kidding me
this is child's play compared to what
i've been through oh god yeah
unable to resolve it a court ordered the
house to be auctioned off leaving half
the profit to the suns and half to the
princhy pesa the estimated value 533
million dollars it failed to attract any
initial bids so now it's up for auction
starting at 320 million still making it
one of the most expensive homes in the
world
for that price tag you might expect a
swimming pool or a tennis court
now here you'll have to settle for a
renaissance masterpiece by none other
than caravaggio it's called jupiter
neptune and pluto it's the only ceiling
painting he ever did so do we know how
much this painting alone is worth
the estimates are
million for that deal throw in several
ancient roman busts
this is cesar augustus from 2ad
just sitting there i know i used to tell
my husband if we had just in new york
it'd be in the middle of our living room
and even a sculpture by michelangelo one
he didn't make for a church when the
principessa moved here almost 20 years
ago she says the house was in shambles
but she made it her life mission to
resurrect it please come in even leading
tours
it feels like a museum with all the
history here but this was more than that
it was a home but my heart will always
be here i feel a great responsibility
part of this will always be in my heart
always forever
[Music]
now the princess is still deciding on
the next chapter of her life but as far
as the villa is concerned well she
thinks it's going to take a jeff bezos
or an elon musk who can actually afford
this treasure trove and there are still
some treasures hiding inside for
instance galileo himself once gazed upon
the stars from this very rooftop and
she's convinced that two of his
telescopes are still hiding in the
ceiling gail
well i'm sure that place is perfect for
somebody chris lips i thank you very
much who is that somebody though who is
that who is that somebody they gotta put
some paint on the wall on the staircase
i just i can imagine teddy running
through there knocking over bosses and
statues i'm not sure that's a home you
necessarily want to live in but it is a
museum if they want it it is a museum
yeah and we like art but i guess we were
just being super cautious by blurring
out the statues we blurred out the
anatomy the male anatomy all right